tu peux me dire ce que c'est c'est un
passeport un passeport pour la liberté
pour tous les gens que je connais
m
je suis un ancien fonctionnaire au
service de l'état
tu est ce qu'on appelle un chacal
c'est un citoyen paisible mais tu
fréquentes des gangsters tu la joues en
solo
mon oncle le milieu c'est ça chez les
gangsters aux règles ses affaires à
coups de poing
allume cigare est mort il ya longtemps
que le petit voyou qui admettent éclopés
de l'écran je suis champion d'arts
martiaux moi je suis ravi de honte à
peine craque et pleure jamais me fous de
savoir qui tu as dans ton carnet
d'adressés pour moi tu n'es qu'un
parasite et je vais t'écraser tout même
mal ans mes chers concitoyens et avec la
plus grande fermeté la plus grande
solennité que je déclare la guerre au
crime par tous les moyens
c'est quoi ce bordel tu te crois l'abri
tête de con
que te prends pour qui sait rien je suis
intouchable dans ce milieu les alliances
se font et se défont celui qui hier
était votre ennemi pourrait être un ami
aujourd'hui